i began this week off showing you the
heartbreaking videos one in particular
of an officer resigning over vaccine
mandates and i said it wouldn't be the
last time we see something like this
unfortunately and i mean this
unfortunately i was right let's check in
from coast to coast first right here in
new york city where mayor bill de
blasio's vaccine mandate is trampling on
the rights and freedoms of new york's
finest
it's a mandate now for all city agencies
all city workers it's time for everyone
to get vaccinated if you choose not to
you have the right to go on unpaid leave
we're going to work with your union to
figure out what happens next but the
bottom line is we're not going to pay
people unless they're vaccinated
you're not fired you're just not going
to get paid de blasio telling the city's
cops do what i say or go home
because this is not about science or
safety if that were the case he wouldn't
be saying goodbye
to the thin blue line that stands in the
way of his citizens and the already
spiking murder rate in this city now
it's about control
these officers already patrolled the
streets during the height of this
pandemic when cases were nearly triple
what they are now and before we even had
a vaccine but now suddenly things are
more dangerous suddenly the nypd can't
do their job if they don't take the shot
what kind of sense does that make and
this authoritarian overreach isn't
unique to new york it's spreading around
the country as police officers are being
forced to choose between their job and
the jab let's travel west in chicago a
city torn apart by carnage and violence
2600 shootings just this year
you would think that the city brass
would be doing everything they could to
not only keep officers they have but go
find new ones add new ones
no
instead mayor lori lightfoot said to
hell with the safety of her city's
residents she just needs she wants
control
life that is willing to lose thousands
of officers over her vax mandate quote
about 2 000 officers had yet to upload
their vaccine or testing status
on a city online portal and so far 21
officers have been stripped of their
police powers and sent home without pay
according to abc
so
chicago has decided compliance more
important than safety
because again the left just wants to get
their way they want control and they're
willing to
dehumanize
dehumanize those that don't follow the
orders that reach that goal look to them
the unvaccinated are the enemy who
should never be associated with they've
said it in their own words look at how
cnn's so-called medical expert leanna
winn characterized it this past summer
what we really need to do at this point
is to make vaccination the easy choice
it needs to be hard for people to remain
unvaccinated
you know what makes life harder losing
your job so the left is succeeding they
have made life incredibly hard difficult
for people who keep us safe make it hard
for those who would stand in the way of
us and violence
let's go further west in seattle where
dozens of cops and firefighters were
forced out over that city's mandate
these brave men and women stood up for
their rights they marched on city hall
to drop off their boots in symbolic
protest
because if seattle won't protect their
freedoms why should they risk their
lives to protect it
the city had just had a summer of love
or so it was called it looks like it's
about to enter
a winter of danger and violence
but at the end of the day we need to
remember these are real people whose
lives are being turned upside down over
a vaccine that didn't exist 24 months
ago
the left wants to make life harder but
these first responders just want to keep
the lives they already had what kind of
country are we when police officers are
collateral damage scratch that they're
targets
in a fight over a vaccine
like this washington state police
due to my personal choice to take a
moral stand against
for
medical freedom and personal choice
i will be signing out of service for the
last time today
after nearly 17 years of serving the
citizens of the state of washington it's
been my honor and privilege to work
alongside all of you we all know in this
district
on the 19th there will be 51 of the 75
troopers available
and only seven of the eleven sergeants
this agency is losing an outstanding
hard-working determined and caring
individual
i'm honored to have been your dispatcher
but mostly proud to be your wife
our future is bright
thank you so much for your service one
time
and thank you for yours and for being by
my side
destroying
not just police forces but families 17
years patrolling the streets and keeping
a community safe are now gone and for
what
lunacy
look we toss around words words
vaccinated unvaccinated we toss around
stats
we're talking about people here you know
what i'm going to take you up on that
let's talk about stats for just one
moment how about this the state of
washington
which we have been talking about their
mandate wouldn't effect on monday three
percent of the state's workforce has
quit or been fired another three percent
has been reassigned another 4.6 is
currently in a state of flux so add that
up and you get over 10
of prison guards firemen healthcare
workers affected by this dehumanization
and that's just in the state of
washington let's take a quick trip back
east now let's come back here to new
york where quote among police 30 percent
are still not vaccinated and among new
york's bravest
quote nearly 45 percent of fdny
firefighters are unvaccinated
you see the cost of these mandates to
our safety to our cities to us
to principled men and women that are
losing their life's work to human beings
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else